[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
je m'en venais sassia
et je vous confesse que je ne
connaissais pas du tout le concept tedx
que j'ai découvert que je ne suis
vraiment pas sur les réseaux sociaux
mais comme on l'en 2022 je me suis
promis d'y aller
donc aujourd'hui je voudrais partager
avec vous une histoire mais comme j'aime
redire aux enfants de mon émission
j'aimerais vous conter une histoire et
cette histoire en fait et les miels
quand j'étais encore une morne une
bambine à l'école primaire un jour des
gens que je ne connaissais pas est
devenue une école primaire m'ont parlé
de prisonniers adoptée par amnesty
international
faut qu'il fallait recueillir le maximum
possible de signature pétitionnaires ce
prisonnier adopté par l'assemblée
nationale avait non nelson mandela
c'est alors que je réalisais que je
prends conscience pour la toute première
fois de la notion des droits bonhomme
d'égalité des droits qu'ils en réalité
n'est pas du tout équitable pour tous
les êtres humains sur terre et figurez
vous j'étais vraiment loin de pressentir
que
la motion ou la lutte contre
les inégalités en droit était genre et
alors après cet épisode là évidemment je
me suis inscrite aux renseignements dont
le club junior à d'amnesty international
et je fus une très très bonne militants
des droits de l'homme jusqu'à mes années
estudiantines
et puis les années sont passées et un
jour de l'an 2000 hommes je me suis
mariée ça fait lourd en s arrêtant ouais
je suis pas
ce pas jean des temps
c'est pas ça l'essentiel
je me suis marié et donc de puivert
printemps bien content et je vise au
côté d'un jeune homme fort ouvert
d'esprit mais d'abord à ce monsieur là
et
et me laisse tout faire
et atypique côté excentrique
s'il y avait deux belles voitures de la
famille je devais rouler la plus belle
je devais prendre des décisions c'est à
dire que avec lui je me sens libre comme
l'air mais problème ans et pas avec lui
que je les ai rencontrés
mémorable et par rapport à l'inégalité
des genres je les ai découverts dans la
société je les ai rencontrés à ineo je
les ai contre est combattue ailleurs
suite d'autres opéras
[Musique]
ignatus nous avons à peu près parce que
mon fils est né à 19 ans j'ai
expérimenté
inexorable vérité douces et amères de ce
qu'on appelle la maternité et je me
rappelle très bien que quand j'étais
enceinte
je sentais sur moi au sein de
l'entreprise même si c'est l'entreprise
de mon époux une forme de pression une
charge mentale qui me demandait un peu
trop ce n'était pas dit ouvertement mais
j'avais l'impression que en tant que
femme enceinte je devais faire beaucoup
d'efforts pour ne pas paraître un
handicap un handicap de la société donc
nous attendons le bébé je travaillais en
plus qu'à l'accoutumée
et là mon cerveau a commencé à
travailler j'ai commencé pas à voir les
choses autrement je j'ai commencé à
comprendre les préjugés sur les femmes
enceintes et j'ai commencé en ligne a
maintenant les femmes en 5 ou va doit
voter différemment prêté dans la société
et c'est eux qu'on sent cela m'a fait
dire non à l'égalité des droits de
certains droits je précise entre femmes
0 puis les années ont continué et je me
suis dit qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
changer les choses mais j'ai ressenti en
moi monique capacité à réagir
un jour évidemment les enfants
grandissant les choses évoluent en
j'ai connu entre temps j'ai eu une
assistante de direction qu'ils
attendaient un bébé et je me rappelle
très bien la réaction de certaines
personnes qui étaient revenus dans
l'entreprise après quand j'avais proposé
une prime une augmentation de salaire ou
une prime tout ce que vous voulez pour
l'encourager parce que cette assistante
lac était la première à venir dans
l'entreprise est venue avant tout c'est
collé mais était la dernière aussi
apporté par terre après tout le monde je
n'oublierai jamais cette phrase-là de
ces commentaires qui disaient est
l'entreprise qui l'a enceinte et vous
imaginez un peu cela
et je me suis dit ça n'est pas juste ça
n'est pas normal
et je continue de penser aujourd'hui
que avec beaucoup de maturité que la
lutte
n'est ce pas des droits surtout des
droits de la femme devait efforts penser
autrement devait être revue devait être
reconsidérée
nous pouvons pas parler d'égalité des
droits
entre la femme et l'homme
dans certaines circonstances je ne
conteste pas l'égalité en droits d'eau
en matière de droits civiques en matière
de droit finale en matière
c'est à l'éducation en matière d'accès à
la santé ou encore mémo microfinance
avec aucun quand une forme de prêts dont
les institutions de microfinance sont
deux mots de laval deux sont membres
c'est fou mais quand on me demande un
prêt à la banque la femme n'est pas
obligé d'être signataire ça ne vous dit
pas quelque chose ça
jeudi il ya plein de choses je dis et je
répète et je suis persuadé que
dans la société d'aujourd'hui
en l'an 2001 p o
quand on parle de à compétences égales
entre femmes et hommes
salé aux ego je dis non je dis vraiment
non ouvrez les yeux réfléchissez un peu
si nous voulons vraiment que notre
société ait une meilleure qualité de vie
si nous voulons vraiment que nos enfants
soient épanouis que la société soit peu
procès que notre humanité vivre mieux ne
devons pas penser en matière d'équité à
la une migration des salaires entre
hommes et femmes de façon égale ce que
je dis est tout simple à compétences
égales entre femmes et hommes salaire
supérieur pour la femme tout simplement
toutes les charges invisible des femmes
on savait plein femmes
quand elles à ces démonstrations
ses serviettes hygiéniques
c'est un budget mensuel de toute vie
active qu'elle est encore en cas de
travail pendant qu'elle est encore
active sous budget
dell à la retraite
les femmes
dépensent et
dessous tous les besoins pour le confort
du quotidien
chargeant qui passent dans la famille
d'employés qu'on ne comptabilise pas ses
besoins et ses dépenses qui sont quand
nexsan supporte monétaire qui ne sont
pas conduites dans la vie du couple la
femme en général ça se joue à nice est
plus onéreuse que celle de l'homme et
figurez-vous sa crosse de santé ces mini
caméra sa féminité alors
que l'on ne connaît pas en général
figurez vous que même si une femme
décide de se la jouer à la gare sont
coupés court quand elle va sur coiffeur
le graphe on nous demande encore plus
que ces faits la langue ou pas l'homme
aux époux une question pourquoi ça soit
les demandes chose et c'est new deal à
la femme les déclas pas souvent parce
que spontanément et porté vers un don
naturel et même vers un centre existant
pour le bien être de sa famille 2 de la
société de son environnement
on demande un peu beaucoup trop à la
femme en sociétés par exemple on lui
demande souvent de prouver ses
compétences intellectuelles personnel
quand même et bardé de diplômes et de
capacités donc la forme carrée et occupe
un poste et ils sont portés vers site
élan à travailler toujours plus sans
oublier la double charge mentale que la
faune à la maison l'éducation des
enfants qu'elle fait au quotidien
tellement de choses aujourd'hui
au fil des ans
au gré du temps
ma vision sur le traitement de la femme
en 106 est en reprise a complètement
changé avec un regard nature je vois
autres nouvelles choses et je pense que
pour que nos enfants soient améliorées
pour que l'humanité
ait évolué en positivité nous devons
changer les hommes la donne
les questions liées à la lutte contre
les inégalités
en fait tu devrais
vraiment changé de position sur une
confidence je ne suis pas une féministe
je me suis toujours senti en dehors de
la lutte féministe parce que dans vos
foyers je ne ressens pas le besoin je ne
me sens pas en conflit
aujourd'hui signe chez le courage de
prendre la parole et d'en parler c'est
suite à toutes ces expériences là que je
vis en dehors de mon poignet que je vie
en société
je continue de penser de soutenir
mordicus que la femme ne peut pas être
également prêté que l'eau
parce que la femme est une
avant-gardiste dans la société la femme
fait tellement de choses qu'on ne
réalise pas je connais
m'exprimer autrement ce que je ressens
et puis vous faut également chargé
d'émotion que je ne sais pas si les mots
pourraient suffire à transcrire cela
mais ce dont je suis persuadé
c'est que aujourd'hui nous les femmes
sommes une majorité que je pourrais dire
insignifiants
majorité parce que bien plus nombreuses
que les hommes sutter nous voit ne sont
pas forcément celles qui sont
plus égalité
je continuerai jeunes sisteron dire
la femme en société on dépense égal
salaire supérieur pour la femme et c'est
moi ou mes spatiale qui le dit et je
n'ai pas si
je continue je persiste les systèmes
pour vous dire que
si nous voulons vraiment changer les
choses
améliorer les choses
devant comme l'a dit paula que je viens
de découvrir avec
tellement de bonheur tellement de
ravissement je suis content parce que
j'ai fait pas super et sociaux je
continue d'imaginer
20022 gouvart et je vais créer une page
facebook
précieuse d'amis mdm a promis je vais
venir et je vais pouvoir la suivre en
direct et tout ça
nous avons le pouvoir de déplaire est ce
que je dis est sincère et ce que je dis
c'est pas complet un
warning vous savez
le fin quittant un enfant en société
mérite je vous dis si ça mérite une
prime dans ses fonctions
en sully l'adx ionnaires et vous verrez
bien que quand on parle de symptômes
c'est à dire ligne à la maladie à la
définition de ce que c'est qu'une
maladie vous lirez des manifestations
telles que la nausée
tels que la courbatures fièvre
indigestion douleurs diverses et femme
les gens passent si un homme à l'un ou
l'autre de ses septs aux émirats
consultez un médecin
mais mise sur la fin qui porte une femme
qui porte la vie elle est assujettie à
tous ces hommes là alors qu'on me dise
pas
être enceinte ça ne veut pas dire être
malade
moi je vous rappelle bien que quand
j'attendais mon premier et mon premier
enfant et que je faisais beaucoup
d'efforts les autres mon entourage ne
vais pas redire oui oui peut pas y être
parce que j'ai évidemment moi je suis
accro du maquillage l'assument j'aime me
sentir belle de me sens et coquette
j'aime me sentir d'où ses canines et je
mets particulièrement un point d'honneur
à être une zone neutralisée où ils me
regardent et happiness commune et b
voici six mois si ça mais j'ai
aujourd'hui
je sais ce que j'ai pris sur moi je sais
que j'ai le sens régies y ait dû faire
face à masi confort lié à ma maternité
géré à malines tellement de choses sur
moi j'ai fait j'ai consenti un paiement
de sacrifices jeudi c'est dommage que
j'ai peint une vie j'ai connu fils mais
si j'avais eu une fille je n'aurais
vraiment dopé contre tous ces
stéréotypes et préjugés
sociaux là sur la femme qui attend un
bébé
d'entreprises parce qu'elle est
considérée comme un gentil soeur du
développement économique de la société
ou de son entreprise et c'est dommage
ils ont à l'égalité de certains droits
entre femmes et hommes
oui pour un traitement équitable et
quand je dis qui table je dis quoi
je profite de cette tribune là
aujourd'hui believe pour pour attirer
votre attention simplement et pour vous
demander de revoir ce que nous appelons
écouter les gens
franchement c'est important pour
je veux dire pour l'épanouissement même
de la société
les femmes
sans la majorité de la société on
demande beaucoup aux femmes quant à
l'harmonie même de la cellule familiale
et paradoxalement ce sont les femmes qui
sont les plus brimer les plus opprimés
il est plus un sujet qui à toutes formes
des scripts la page
les femmes sont celles qui donne la vie
elle représente
le symbole même de la pérennisation de
l'espèce humaine mais paradoxalement
leur voix dans les instances de famille
le véto son émoi les femmes sont ceux
qui travaillent le plus avec la bonne
charge de travail à la maison et au
boulot et paradoxalement ce sont elles
les plus pauvres de la planète
les femmes sont les plus nombreuses du
monde mais paradoxalement
elles sont les mots écoutez est moins
haut présentée dans nos diverses
instances sociales politiques tout ce
que vous voulez
les femmes
sont la majorité du monde je l' ai bien
dit un représentant pratiquement rien et
aujourd'hui les filles chantent cette
insignifiante majorité l'a imaginé vous
simplement
balance de cette somme insignifiante
majorité et cette vision là regardez la
plus grande majorité dans une balance
et la petite majorité dans une autre
cette balance que représentent les
femmes plus pour imaginer simplement
qu'elle devient plus prospère nous voyez
vous pas que ça va équilibrer le moz
tout simplement ce que je dis
compétences égales entre femmes et
hommes
salaire supérieur pour la femme on
conclura
je voudrais dire
je vous zapper ou chefs d'entreprise vos
leaders de vos communautés respectives
a octroyé
[ __ ]
supérieur à vos collaborateurs et c'est
un défi que je relance
et on se donne rendez-vous dans quelques
années je suis vraiment déçu a dès que
vous me remercierez mais pour l'instant
c'est moi qui vous remercie de m'avoir
suivi